okay cool uh welcome everyone
to this last day of itcs uh
so for the first session the session
will be on machine learning
so you remember the format we have
five talks eight minutes each talk and
then after that
we have a panel where we can ask all the
questions
feel free if you do have a clarification
question feel free to ask during the
talk
but for the deeper question let's keep
them at the end
and for the first talk we have kung hae
from shenzhen university
hello everyone today i will talk about
dynamic influence
in probabilistic graphic models this is
joint work
with women xiaomi and eton
but first let me define the graphic
model
given a graph it will be the set of
vertices
and the e bit set of eights suppose each
vertex
is a random variable that takes its
value from the final domain q
and each edge is a constraint defined on
its
variables for each variable v
we give it a with function v
the function marks the assignment of we
to a real
number for each constraint e
we give it a function v this function
marks
the assignment of all the variables in
this constraint
to a real number thus
for each configuration sigma in q to the
v
value configuration is an assignment of
all the random variables
so weight of sigma is e
to the sum of the width functions power
now we can use variables constraints
domain and weight functions to specify
a graphic model graphic model defines
or gives this a gibbs distribution
such that the probability of each comp
is office configuration is is
proportional to its weight
the graphic model is important in many
research
in many research areas one of the most
important computational tasks for
graphic model
is to estimate the distribution of a
vector of random variables
this problem is very motivated and also
well studied
given a graphic model there are three
kinds of inference problem
including the marginal influence the
posterior influence
and the maximum of posterior inference
there are different methods for
probabilistic influence
in all these methods the mcmc sampling
is the most widely applicable
given a graphic model the sampling
algorithm
draws random samples from gibbs
distribution thus
one can perform the influence by
sampling as follows
firstly draw an i independent samples
x from mu i such that the total variance
distance
between x and mui is bounded
next estimate the target probabilities
that i from these samples
nowadays the big data proposes
new challenges for the inference
algorithms
the ground the graphic models from big
data
uni have huge size moreover
these models updated frequently
so the difference between the instance
between before and after i update the
units more
for these models running the whole
influence algorithm
for each update is to time cost
for example if the mcmc sampling is used
the expected running time is known as
sun
the product of an eye and the size of we
however the size of we can be as much as
several buildings the size and
and i can be as several millions
another example is the practical
algorithms
for learning the graphic models
in these algorithms the optimal model
i star is obtained by updating the
parameters of the graph
model iteratively for this algorithms
running the core inference algorithm for
each update
is also to time cost
thus in this paper we consider the
dynamic influence problem
given a graph model i and set i
denote the target probability vector
and that heart i denote is estimator
in dynamic inference we'll know the
graph model itself
can change dynamically with time
specifically one can add and delete
variables and
constraints and change the width
functions
the goal is to calculate the new
estimator
that heart i prime my question
in this paper is that can we modify the
heart
i to that heart high prime with a small
incremental cost
such that this part i prime is
a reasonable estimator
thus the dynamic inference problem
can be formulated as follows
input is the original instance i
the original estimator the heart i and
the updated instance i prime
the output should be a newest method of
the updated
instance to accelerate the inference
algorithm
extra data structure decided in the
memory is also or not
in this paper we assume that all the
updates
are generated by all of offline
adversary
in other words the updated is
independent with the randomness used by
the algorithm
we also assume that the difference
between i
and i prime is stunted otherwise there
is no faster algorithm
because there is no faster dynamic
algorithm
than the static inference here
the difference between the two instances
is defined as follows
main contribution of this work is a new
algorithm
that solves the dynamic influence
problem efficiently
for upload for broadcast class of
graphic models
our algorithm is fast we proved that
if i and i prime has polylog rhythmic
bounded maximum degree
and satisfy the double channels
selectment condition then
the expected running time of our
algorithm is
bounded by the sum of an i prime
and the size of v prime
actually for most such instances
the only applicable static inference
acquisition
is the mcmc sampling
as the expected running time of the
static sampling
is no less than the product of an eye
prime and
the size of v prime therefore
our dynamic algorithm achieves a
significant speed up
thank you thank you very much
great perfectly on time so we are now
going to move to the next dock
[Music]
yes go ahead okay
and yeah hi i'm jonathan
and i'll be telling you a little bit
about the paper interactive proof
for verifying machine learning this is a
joint work with shafi goldwater
guy ross bloom and emilio dayoff
and the question we considered is when
is verify on
cheaper than learning and we're all
familiar with the
idea that for some computational tasks
finding a solution can be
a lot harder than verifying a solution
provided by somebody else but
what about supervised machine learning
are there supervised machine learning
tasks where finding a good hypothesis
is a lot harder than verifying a
hypothesis provided by somebody else
and of course we're interested in
knowing uh other cases like that
when is that the case how big can the
gap be between
learning and verifying and so on
and the model we use is the following
so there's some unknown distribution
that provides
a sampled with the form some instance
and the label of that instance
and there is a verifier who's interested
in
finding a hypothesis that can predict
the labels for that distribution
however the verifier doesn't want to do
all the hard work of finding that
hypothesis
by itself and therefore it can use the
help of
a learner approver which is another
party that might have more computational
resources but is not trusted
both the verifier and the prover can
take samples from the unknown
distribution
and they can send each other messages
when they finish the interaction the
verifier will either
output some hypothesis or reject the
interaction
let's see an example where this kind of
setting is useful
so imagine you're
you have some commercial setting where
there's a
company visa verifier that's interested
in performing some machine learning
tasks
and they choose to outsource that
machine learning task to another company
the provider
or approve a p what p is supposed to do
is it's supposed to collect a lot of
high quality data
and invest a lot of compute power and so
on on training a good machine learning
model for this
particular task and then they send
whatever
model they develop to the verifier and
the verifier sees let's say that
this model has an accuracy of perhaps 80
so keep in mind that the verify can
always
get a good estimate of what the true
accuracy of the
model is simply by taking you know a
small number of samples
and seeing what percentage of them were
labeled correctly by this model
but if we see that the accuracy is 80
should the verifier
accept or reject maybe eighty percent is
the best possible
but maybe if the maybe the verifier was
actually not doing a very good job and
if they would have invested more
resources etc
than they would have gotten to 95
percent so
should the verifier accept or reject
so inspired by the definition of
path learning probably approximately
correct learning from running theory
uh we propose a definition of pac
verification
which goes as following so some class h
of functions from a domain x
to label 0 1 and there's a
loss function which for each hypothesis
in the class tells us
how good or bad it performs in
predicting the labels
and the objective is to get low loss
and then there's this number here opt
which is the best
possible loss that one can achieve using
hypothesis
from the class h so this is a minimal
possible loss
and the objective of the verifier would
be to output a hypothesis
that with high probability satisfies
this inequality which says that the
the loss of the hypothesis is
nearly optimal the most epsilon worse
than optimal
and as i said earlier estimating the
loss of the particular hypothesis
uh provided by the approver is a
relatively easy from hosting's
inequality you can take a small number
of samples and that would be a good
estimate
however it's much harder for the
verifier to know what the value of oct
is
because opt involves the losses of all
the hypothesis in the class
h which might be a big and complicated
class
and that's where the approver comes in
the prover basically needs to convince
the verifier that oct is large enough
to satisfy this inequality let's see an
example
where this is possible so we call this
certificates of large loss
and the class we're using is the simple
threshold functions
over the interval zero one so you start
off at zero and then at some point it
jumps up to one
and you wanna find the the the best
point to jump up to one
um so what the prover can do
for this particular class is it concerns
uh
two sets a and b each of them is an
event within the probability space of
the unknown distribution
where a is as the event that
a point falls within this interval and
is labeled one
so it looks like this and b is also an
interval it's a it's a probability it's
the event where
a point falls within this interval and
is labeled
and for the law uh the requirements that
a is to the left of b so all the points
in a are smaller than all the points in
b
um why is this useful
so when v receives these two events
a and b what it can do is it can
estimate the weight
of a and estimate the weight of b again
by half things inequality just take a
small number of samples and see
what percent of them fall within vivian
day and what percent of them fall within
their identity
and it turns out that opt
is um lower bounded by the minimum of
these two weights
and the reason for that is simply that
if i have some
uh monotone increasing threshold that
classifies
even a single point in a correctly then
that means that from that point
and to the right everything else must be
classified as one
and therefore all the points in b are
classified incorrectly
and vice versa if you classify even one
point in b correctly that means you're
classifying all the points in a
incorrectly because if the classifier
must remain at zero till that point
and so the loss the event of
misclassifying is
has probability at least the minimum of
these two events
two minutes
yes and so using this idea we're able to
prove
um a result which uh says that there's
a um a quantitative separation between
learning and verifying a quadratic
separation
in sample complexity and the idea is to
use this
um idea from vessels generalize it to
a class with these thresholds it has vc
dimension d
and then the certificate involves 2d
events and not just
two events and then you can use results
from distribution testing to test that
all those events satisfy a certain
condition
using square root d samples so that's
our first result
and our second result says kind of the
opposite
that in some cases it's not possible to
um
verify more true prison learning and our
third result
uh says that in some cases there's a
qualitative separation so there are all
classes
where you cannot learn using random
samples but you can learn
using a query access to the target
function
so you can't run using random samples
but you can verify
using random samples that's our third
result
and um to summarize we saw the
definition
of a path verification we saw that there
is
sometimes a quantitative separation
sometimes not
there's a case with a qualitative
separation where
it is suffices to you can use random
samples to verify
but learning requires a query access
um and uh that's pretty much it for
future directions i think two
interesting directions are to
um find a complete characterization of
uh the sample complexity gap between
learning and verifying
and also to find efficient pac
verification protocols for some
real-world classes of hypothesis that
are used
for machine learning thank you very much
perfect thank you very much
so we can now move to the next talk
on training over parametrized neural
networks in near linear time and
uh being you peng is gonna be giving the
talk
okay uh okay next that are starting now
yeah please go ahead yeah thanks uh
thanks
for everyone for coming uh i'm going to
talk about a little about a little bit
of our about our paper
uh about over a training oral
primatories the neural network in near
linear time
and uh i'm being from colombia
university
and this is john walker with jen brand
uh joseon and army uh james from kth
uh is from uh from columbia and uh
joe is from princeton
okay uh okay i'll start talking about a
little bit about neural net
so neonite is the most powerful tool in
the past decade
and it works very well in practice i
will give two examples
the first example is about image
recognition on image night
so the performance on the internet keeps
increasing
and it finally beats the human level in
the year of 2015
and also the second example is
apocalypse
and alphago uh is the top human player
of gold game
uh in the year of 2017. okay
well the deep learning works very well
in practice it's we're still
lack of understanding of it in siri and
there are many uh topics here for
example the robotness
and also the deep learnings lack of
implantation and extra
so but in this work in this work well we
will focus on
a specific aspect we will focus on uh
speed up neural network training and uh
the outline of this target is just
follow
i will first give a very general
introduction to neural net
and i will motivate our question and the
second i'll
introduce a little bit of over
parameterized neural network
and finally i will uh present our result
on your linear
time training algorithm okay okay first
i will
talk about the motivation behind our
problem uh okay
here's a here a few facts about neural
nets so first uh the number of a neural
net could be very large
for example it could be over 10 million
parameters for rats 918
and the the the amount of primaries
could be even larger if we if the neural
net gets deeper
and the second fact is that training
neural net could be really really slow
for example it takes over seven days uh
on eight gpus
for just training a single uh state of
state of art language model called bird
and so yeah as one can see like
the the train time could really be a
bonus like our practical
uh deep learning and the key question we
consider here is that can we step up
neural network training
so yeah i mean there's no surprise that
there are having extensive effort on
this topic
so from practitioner there are many
racing mastered but
in general there are lack of serious
guarantees and some of them
are not very scalable and they are only
target for one specific
task from the series side there have
been many many advances in organization
theory
over the last decades but most of them
only work for comex operation but that
wasn't
as one or as one know the neural network
could be
uh non-complex and non-smooth so um the
loss of
this theory cannot be uh applied
directly to neural net
okay so before i move on so actually
there's a it's a cabinet here
so so the the problem here is that how
can we reason about the competition cost
if we are not even clear about the
organization landscape
to be particular we are well not even
unclear about whether the greeting
descent
or the stochastic grid descent can
converge and
whether it can converge uh to a color
organ and the
how many iterations the gradient design
can converge
okay uh yeah but fortunately uh we
we will study this problem uh under the
over prime trust and neural network
uh regime and uh and we will we will use
this recent advance from
uh ml and siri communities uh just in
the last
few years and uh okay what was the
overall prime trust the framework
is about so it's a work done by two
separate
the group of people one is by two jai
apostle sign and the other by alan ju
lee and song in both in 2019 and uh the
okay the cinema
roughly stayed as full so it says when
the width of the neural network
is sufficiently large then the
stochastic gradient descent
and the gradient descent can probably
converge to
the global optimal and the train allows
can converge to zero
okay we will start the problem under
this framework but
uh and i will begin to
talk about the basic setup of our paper
so for just for
uh for the standard neural net uh we
consider one hidden layer neural net
and we assume there are untrained data
drawn id from the
from the distribution and yeah and
and we assume the input of uh feature
lasting a d dimensional space
and we consider the activation function
to be relu
and uh just for clarity where we use end
to need to know the number of training
data
and to denote the width of the neuron
and d to denote the input dimension
and uh okay what's our over parameters
for neural net
uh overpriced the overall parameters
means
that the weights of the neuron of the
neural net is much larger
than some poly factor of n so
so essentially it says the number of
neuron is much larger
of the in the first layer okay uh
our main result of this paper is to
present the first linear linear time
training algorithms
and as one can see from this chart uh
yeah essentially the number of tuition
is
just our very log factor
and we achieve uh m n uh cost per
iteration
and this is uh almost tight and linear
in the
input dimension okay uh then i will
slightly uh talk about the main
techniques
uh used in our paper so roughly speaking
we use approximate newton method
and we achieve some uh
speed up by preconditioning we're
sketching
so yeah so very roughly speaking the key
step in our algorithms is to
do the following uh gradient update
where here the w is the weight matrix f
is the prediction of the neural net
and j is the jacobi matrix and actually
the main cause comes from
just computing g times g transpose which
already takes admin squares
uh yeah and our solution is to just
approximately compute this j times the
transpose
and prove that the the training that the
training outcomes is
actually robust to small laws uh lucifer
and the one one very simple idea is is
that maybe one can just use both gl to
uh
compute this j times c transpose uh but
the
the problem here is that the conditional
number actually
proves matters involved problem if we
just simply use fast jl then it will
bring a
large over additive overhead on end
so instead we we divide this the whole
training procedure into two steps in the
first step we've solved just a
regression problem and
in the second step we use the solution
of the regression problem and do the
gradient updates
so this somehow decouples the question
and in the first step we
just use some size facing back detecting
to facilitate the pre-conditioning
and after we do this conditioning we can
just do greeting descent to solve this
regression problem
and we will get a very high precision
with very little
uh uh computation calls and iterations
and
uh yeah and basically that's all of the
option
and finally i remarked that the
technique jackets can
a much more have much wider applications
and they
can also achieve some speed up on some
combat examination problems as well
okay finally i'll point some future
directions on this paper
uh yeah so there could be many
uh future work on this uh for example
one can improve the dependence on the
ways
or one can maybe uh extend our result to
multiple layer but i
will point on one specific a specific uh
interesting direction that uh
that's to to use some random randomized
linear algebra in neural network
training
so so first uh the the dimension
reduction technique has been start
extensively studied in the tcs community
but it has only been recently used to
uh to practice neural network training
just in the last
two or three years and the question here
is that can we
do more uh on this and uh the second
question is that so this paper provides
the first attempt to import randomized
linear algebra to neurological training
with approval theoretical guarantees and
the question is
is can we do more and uh maybe one
challenging question is
can we go beyond the over primary trust
and neural network
framework and develop some like uh uh
you you you use the randomized linear
algebra and provide some fast training
algorithms for
practical on your internet okay thanks
thank you very much uh let's move
quickly to the next
to the next talk uh on counter examples
to the low degree conjecture
okay you can take it away alex
uh great yeah thanks a lot
um okay so this is joint work with
justin holmgren
so i want to talk about uh these high
dimensional testing problems so
for example this uh problem you may have
heard of is called planted clique
so plenty clique is about distinguishing
between two different distributions
in the first distribution which we call
the null model you just get a random
graph
as n vertices each possible edge occurs
with probability one-half
on the other hand in the planted model
you get a random graph
with a planted k clique meaning i've
taken k vertices
and connected them all to each other
that's called a clique that's what's
shown in red here
and so the idea is that i give you a
graph either comes from the null or
planted distribution
and you have to decide which one it was
and you want to succeed with error
probability
going to 0 as n goes to infinity
and so there are all sorts of other
problems that um
have a similar type of flavor where
there's some kind of a planted signal
and buried in some kind of noise and
your goal is to detect the presence
or non-presence of this signal
all right so for these types of problems
the phenomenon of a statistical to
computational gap
has been observed in all sorts of
situations
so what does this mean uh again in the
planted clique
setting this problem has been observed
to have these three different phases
depending on the size of the clique
so as k the clique size gets bigger
um you know first it's just
statistically impossible to detect the
clique
um when k is quite big bigger than
roughly root n
it's the problem's easy meaning we know
a polynomial time algorithm
and then in the middle is this sort of
conjectured hard regime
where statistically you can do it if
you're willing to check all the possible
cliques
but we don't know a polynomial time
algorithm
and we kind of think this is fundamental
that really there should not exist
such an algorithm but we don't know how
to prove this even assuming something
like p not equal np
or some standard assumption from
complexity
um so instead typically we try to give
some kind of
formal evidence to explain why these
types of problems are hard
and so this can include for instance
average average case reductions
this means like if you believe planted
clique is hard you can use this to show
some other problems hard
or uh sum of squares lower bounds or
other lower bounds against
certain classes of algorithms but one of
one method i want to talk about today is
based on low degree polynomials
and so this idea of you know thinking of
low degree polynomials as a restricted
class of algorithms
is inspired by this line of work on the
sum of squares hierarchy which has been
very influential and
so basically when i say a low degree
algorithm i just mean
a multivariate polynomial that takes in
your whole input
and outputs a number so you can imagine
for instance
if the input is a random graph there's n
choose two variables
you get to take any multivariate
polynomial you like
in all of these variables
and when i say low degree you should
think logarithmic in the dimension
okay and so what exactly does it mean
for such an algorithm to
succeed at a testing problem well here's
uh one definition to have in mind so
under the
null distribution your polynomial has
expectation zero
under the planted distribution as
expectation one
um you know nothing's special about zero
and one just that they're kind of
separated by a constant
um and then in either case the variance
is little of one
right so if this if these conditions
hold then clearly i can
distinguish the two distributions just
by thresholding this polynomial
by chebychev's inequality
and what's nice about this particular
definition is that it's actually
tractable to analyze
both in terms of upper and lower bounds
and for lower bounds we typically show
that even the first three conditions
cannot be achieved
ignoring this one in red and so for
problems like
so for plenty cleat for instance we now
know that low degree algorithms succeed
in this conjunct in this easy regime
where algorithms are known
low degree algorithms fail in the
conjectured hard regime okay and this is
somehow
not specific to planted clique um for
all of these
sort of high dimensional testing
problems that i listed on the previous
slide
we generally sort of believe that these
low-degree polynomials are as powerful
as all polynomial time algorithms
so for all the problems i listed before
we have now verified that
low degree polynomials are as good as
the best known
polynomial time algorithms and
roughly why this happens is because the
best known algorithms for these things
are often some kind of a spectral method
where you build some matrix and do power
iteration
and this can be implemented uh as a
polynomial of degree
log n okay so this is uh
this is very nice because it lets us
kind of predict in sort of an automatic
way
you know when problems are easy when
they're hard and sort of explain these
statistical to computational gaps um and
particularly the method of analysis is
like fairly simple compared to
things like sum of squares lower bounds
or average case reductions
and so this method is like quite broadly
applicable
um but of course there's some uh limit
to the class of problems where we sort
of believe this conjecture
one example is the uh three or planted
xor
sat and the reason is that you can solve
it using gaussian elimination but
low degree polynomials cannot implement
gaussian elimination
um but you know the the low degree
prediction is not completely wrong
because
if you instead consider just a slightly
noisy version of
xor sat then gaussian elimination stops
working
and now the prediction agrees with the
best known algorithms
okay and so we'd kind of like to
formalize this informal conjecture
especially if we want to use it in other
areas of computer science like
cryptography or something to
um argue why things should be hard
but you know to do this we really need
to formalize this notion of natural like
what exactly
is the class of problems where we
believe that low degree polynomials are
optimal of two minutes polynomial time
algorithms thanks
and so um the first attempt to sort of
write down a formal version of this
conjecture is by
sam hopkins in his phd thesis
and here's sort of an informal statement
of his formal conjecture
um basically you assume that q has id
entries
which is the case for pointed clique
right you have these edges being id
the planted distribution should be
symmetric
uh like most high dimensional problems
are
and then you assume that log degree
polynomials fail to distinguish
and then the conclusion is that no
polynomial time algorithm can
distinguish q
from a noisy version of p where this
noise operator
um you know with a small probability it
resamples each entry of
each entry from uh q this basically just
adds a little bit of noise to rule out
counter examples like the xor
okay and the symmetry you know typically
problems have it but
not clear if it's needed and so here's
basically what
we show in this work we actually refute
this conjecture
by giving a counter example the counter
example is a little bit unnatural in
that
each entry of p is a real number
whose binary expansion encodes a lot of
information
but there's sort of a simple way to fix
the conjecture so that
the we no longer know how to refute it
and it's that the noise operator should
corrupt
every entry a little bit instead of
resampling
just a few entries and the reason is to
sort of destroy all these low order bits
and then our second contribution is to
show that the symmetry is necessary
in the sense that if you remove the
symmetry
condition completely then you can also
refute the conjecture
and this somehow refines our
understanding a bit of what types of
problems
we expect the um low degree algorithms
to be optimal for
roughly speaking the proof uses error
correcting codes and you can look at the
full version of the talk for that
uh thanks a lot perfect thank you very
much right on time
um so we're gonna move to the
last talk of the session before we move
to the panel
and all the questions and i hope there
will be many because these are really
great talks
[Music]
the sound is really weird i don't know
if you can get closer to the mic or
something
i can yeah i can buy let me try
that no it sounds
i mean let me try to turn down your
speaker
type
sorry about that
uh yes but it's still the same sound
could it be because you're not muted
sebastian and you're not using
headphones so the sound goes back
oh you think it's me uh yeah sure
uh it better for everyone all right
oh is that your feedback no it's a lot
better
okay sounds good all right so
yeah so just to just to recover very
quickly
uh in here labels um we take in
two inputs and here we develop them by
h1
which is a real number and then
many layers in each layer
combination specifically for example
this is not
the input of this node would be w1 x1
plus w2 x2 and so on and so on include w
and xn
and this is passed through an activation
function
which is the output of this node
each layer can be multiple nodes and
these give multiple outputs this output
can then be used as input to the next
node and so on and so forth
so in fact these people typically use
very deep networks but
in theory even uh small or even
uh shallow levels we don't understand
very well and specifically this board we
only consider
depth to network where the activation
function in the middle layer
it's just a variable activation so this
is that function that it takes in
somewhere number c and the output is
just the max between c and zero
uh and finally uh the top node in our
setting is just the identity
so our output is just a linear
formulation of the output from the
middle
layer and throughout this song i will
use k
to denote the number of variable nodes
in this middle layer
and i will use
that at all so with this notion in mind
uh our level is a very simple function
so just
in case and the output is just sum over
i
of a i times the ratio of wi
dot x okay so on this
regular very simple networks we study
two problems the first is the training
problem
where we are given a state test of level
samples
so these are samples x and y where x is
the input and y is the
desired output and our goal is to find a
radius that gives an output that is as
close as possible to the desired output
and it is measured by some loss function
specifically the quality at the
last year would be the average overall
example
of some loss function of the actual
output of the network
[Laughter]
this level is a very simple plus
function which is
the square root so this is f x minus y
squared
and there are two ways to keep in mind
that
complexity will be slightly different
so people can realize that okay
where there is an unknown uh uh
that actually fits the data perfectly so
it achieves zero error
another case is a so-called animosity
case where
this might not be true another
very good problem we study here is the
learning problem
it's exactly the same as the training
problem it said that
uh there is an unknown
[Laughter]
giving an algorithm uh just giving a
learning algorithm
but
partners here foreign we need some
normalizing assumptions specifically we
assume that the weights vector through
each
of the node as normal and very important
also as normal most wonderful
okay so after the result can be divided
into
three groups so in behind as results
algorithms and running kind of programs
so the first and most basic result is
that we show that
trending one radio is already entering
in the economic case
when you approximate to a really harsh
factor and only that here for one value
we need the agnostic setting so in the
realizable settings
which can be written as a really program
so it's easy
however from the realizable setting it
turns out that as long as you have
two or more uh number of radio nodes it
also becomes empty
as well there
there's a question by ryan he has his
hands raised you can you can ask your
question right
okay i don't know maybe maybe it was a
mistake of it on this part
okay keep keep going sorry i'm sorry
yeah
okay all right yeah so
uh just to believe that there have been
uh
but it turns out that if you are okay
with additive error
you can still do quite well specifically
in the enclosure there is a
learning algorithm that takes time
exponential in
probably kp or epsilon square times a
polynomial
and if you are in the realizable case
this exponent can be uh
medium to probably kt or epsilon
and normally that uh the dependency on
electronic
diagnostic here is one over epsilon
square whereas is one over epsilon
so it might be it's pretty natural to
pass whether
this is the identity or not or whether
we should be uh
hoping to get a faster algorithm for
diagnostic case
and uh to answer this question we prove
our type one profound
is no
self-explanatory angle a algorithm
cancels to exactly
the second one is a gap eth which is a
strengthening of pdf
that says that two levels cannot get
approximately that well
so under the gap ethics assumption we
show that in the realizable case the one
over epsilon
of the exponent is needed for the energy
case we show that the
final restaurant square is needed and we
need an assumption
that we call fbs basically we say that
approximately in this case our product
of exponential time
constant factor cannot be done and with
this uh we get
that the one squared exponent is needed
for diagnostic
separation between these two settings
uh yeah i did not move in here uh
there are some open equations uh one
interesting one is
we don't get the tight lunch and low one
in terms of k
so that might be interesting um another
interesting one is to improve
uh target hardness for people network
even for a depth
network we don't know if that um another
last one here is to string strengthening
the harness to the important learning
case where you can output
not just k value but also other
arbitrary functions as well
uh and with that uh thank you very much
for your attention great thank you very
much passing
uh so now we're done with the talks and
we're moving to the
panel part of the session so we have at
least you know a good 10 minutes
for discussion and and questions so
please don't be shy
let's you know make this interactive and
and ask questions
uh i can kick things off with uh with a
small
technical question maybe for uh
being you on on the training of over
parameterized neural networks
um so one thing which was not clear in
your talk is whether you need to make
any assumption on the data which i i
assume you do
but maybe you can comment on what do you
need
from the data for the crm that you
mentioned to hold
okay yeah i think when we need some
separation
assumption on the data so we assume
basically assume for the training data
they are
uh their power distance is at least
third
i think that's an assumption but uh the
other another like a common assumption
uh in this field they assume
like the some the some define some
kernel matrix and we assume the
at least the eigenvalue of this kernel
matrix is some
so some prime is at least some like
lambda
and uh these two assumptions are
actually close
relative but yeah we need some
assumption
this this lambda it's assumed for the
expected kernel matrix
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i mean yeah yes
it's assumed on the expected kernel
matrix but
yeah yeah i see i see and then under
this assumption
it's not true like you won't have a
strong convexity
property like it is it
you know i was just wondering like you
you you
you do newton's method to get this log
number of iterations
but do we know that gradient descent
itself will not have a log number of
iterations in this setting
uh yeah yeah the gradient is also
i mean here the number of iterations
like an n squared times log one
x also so i mean uh
yeah but i think that the overhead is
lit is actual uh
n square term and so why why is it
n squared times log one over epsilon is
it because i mean is the smoothness or
is it the strong convexity that's
uh yeah i i think
essentially if you will ask this as a
convex
problem then the conditioner number is
something like a skirt and
so but but so okay so so this and square
term come from
two part one maybe it's just like the
condition number is like
square then so you cannot uh sorry
condition number is n so you can output
scores then and the other is that uh
you you you you need to take this
learning rate to be
somehow very small so this one that will
increase the
like another iteration yeah
okay cool thanks for the clarification
um there is a talk in the chat by
itamar halevi who asked for alex
in the counter example to hopkins
conjecture
that drop symmetry relates to drop out
of part of data
i'm not sure what that means
um yeah i guess i don't know what
dropout of data means exactly but by
symmetry i mean the assumption that
you know the problem itself is highly
symmetric like in planted clique you
have
a distribution over random graphs where
every node in the graph is sort of
treated
the same as every other node so that
type of symmetry is
typically present in these
high-dimensional testing problems
and uh the yeah the dropping symmetry
meant
if we moved to a problem that did not
necessarily have that
type of symmetry so i have another
question for you alex
i mean which will show really my
limitations in in computational
complexity but
the the hopkins conjecture
relates to polynomial time algorithm
like a separation with polynomial
polynomial time algorithm but this seems
very strong because
i mean planted clique you can solve it
in end to the login
and and it's related to the fact that
you know
it's very subtle this login degree
because again
log squared and degree uh will work
so i don't know he said do you have any
comment about this like
it seems it's not between you know um
yeah exponential power and uh
yeah you're absolutely right that that
in planted clique particularly there's a
pretty fine line between easy and hard
where
yeah exactly as you said log degree
polynomials succeed uh fail
or sorry if we're in the hard regime of
planting clique log degree polynomials
fail but
log squared degree polynomials succeed
um yeah for a lot of other problems like
spice pca
or community detection there's a much
more pronounced
gap where like you know in the hard
regime you really need
exponential time so we think um but
yeah so planted clique is actually one
of the easier hard problems in some
sense
and and for these other problems you see
a bigger gap because you need
a much higher larger degree for the for
the polynomial
is that what you're saying yeah exactly
for something like
um the stochastic block model in the
easy regime
you know polynomials of log degree
succeed but then when you move to the
hard regime suddenly you need
polynomials of degree basically n
i see so there's a there's a more
general form of the conjecture that like
if um that polynomials of degree
n to the delta correspond to run time of
like e to the n to the delta
so you can actually sort of um i see if
you care about subexponential runtimes
you can also sort of see this in the low
degree polynomials
yeah very nice uh oh i see two
hands uh being raised let me see how can
i detect
who they are maybe just speak up because
i don't like i don't see who it is
oh i see cameron yep
yeah um i had a question like concerning
the two neural net talks like
for these hard i wanted to try to
understand like one of these talks is
giving efficient algorithms one's giving
harness like
for the second talk like could you get
around your hardness by saying
i train a network that's a little bit
wider but competes with
the best error on my network like is
that like one approach to get around the
hardness or
yeah does that make sense yeah yeah so
yeah that makes perfect sense for our
original only
host against uh if you are related to
our good career
and enhance the proper learning that i
said during this talk
but yeah if you are allowed to our
that is faster than our running time but
it's impossible but if i understand
correctly that their
output is some sort of polynomial so
it's not exactly
like just a little bit or a little bit
deeper networks
i see thanks
uh tal you had a question
yes hi this is a question to alex you
mentioned uh very quickly something
about oh if we want to use the hardness
for cryptography
i wanted to ask if you know look can you
say something about any known
connections between the
planted clique i guess the hard versions
of it
and cryptography one direction or
another
um yeah i mean so
uh my co-author justin is really the
expert on this
part but this was sort of like what
originally motivated us a little bit
to look into this is you know whether
this type of hardness assumption
can be used in other places i believe
the planted clique hypothesis has
already been used in some
type of cryptography but if you assume
planted clique is hard
this implies that um some some hardness
that's useful in cryptography
and so you know this slow degree
conjecture potentially opens the doors
to
uh giving evidence that all sorts of
other problems are hard and maybe this
could help more broadly
but yeah i don't have i don't know
enough to say something more specific
unfortunately
okay and on the other direction you also
don't know like can you prove
hardness of some version based on some
crypto assumption
prove that planted clique is hard if you
assume i don't know lwe or something
like that
i believe this is not known yeah this
would be great if we could do this
um but i don't think it's known yeah
alex there is another question for you
in the chat is there an analog of the
low degree conjecture for optimization
slash
search i see
yeah so these are this is for a problem
um where you don't have a planted signal
and you're just finding
uh you know find a large clique in a
planted in a random graph or something
yeah so we have we have studied this
problem this type of problem or this
problem specifically from a low degree
um point of view and we
yeah there is a sense in which we can
show that low degree polynomials
can find a you know a
clique of the conjectured size and
not bigger than that
um yeah so this stems from join work
with myself and uh david gumarnick and
coach juggernoth
um but yeah i mean formalizing the
conjecture is a bit different like
the conjecture would be more like uh you
know what exactly is the class of
optimization problems for which we
believe low degree polynomials are
optimal
i don't think anyone has rigorously
tried to
write down a conjecture of this form but
certainly one could
could try to do this yeah um
does this answer the question yeah um
uh from one of the attendee has a
question
i just gave you the option to speak up
yep all right uh uh i had a query
uh with respect to the debt to relu
networks so uh your uh
results point out to the best hypothesis
in the case of uh dynamic graphs
for the uh adapt to uh our relu
networks are there uh specific
uh uh networks that you want to
extend this uh in
in the case of further
analysis or i was thinking
more in a general sense in which you can
have some sort of
convolutions or attentions that can be
argumented to this current network to
extend or scale in a much uh
uh how do i say it uh
um uh in a depth network
uh uh fashion uh so that it can be
um generalized to a much
uh yeah
yeah i think that that's a very good
question uh i guess one thing i
mentioned
is about the three network but for your
like
the network that we consider is only uh
fully connected input so you could also
try to ask them about
thank you great
uh and i have a question for jonathan
schaefer so i was just wondering do you
think there is an analog of vc dimension
for verification come again
uh is there an analog of vc dimension
uh for verification yeah so that's
uh an open problem that i think would be
very interesting to
uh look at um at the moment
uh we know a lower bound
of square root d for verification where
d
is the bc dimension but
we we don't have any further um
characterization of the of the sample
complexity guys
i see so no upper bound at all in terms
of the
i i guess it's always upper bounded by
bc
but i think that would be a very
interesting direction
mustafa has a question
um yes thank you for having me
to get this great opportunity so my
question is for the second paper
interactive crews for verifying machine
learning
i've been wondering whether there are
any implications for
computational complexity theory are
machine learning problems
special in any way such that applying
interactive proofs on them
shed new lights on complexity theory
uh i think your question was what is the
difference between
uh complexity here in the case of
verification of machine learning
versus general uh computational
complexity
that was a question i'm not yes i mean
by complexity computational complexity
theory
yeah so if you think like the
differences in computational complexity
you're talking about uh algorithms that
have some fixed input
and you want to find an output while in
uh
learning you don't have a fixed input
there's some unknown distribution
and you get a random sample from that
distribution
and then you need to put an output for
that so
it's not it's not exactly the same
because the
there's no fixed input
so there are no implications on
understanding the fundamental limits of
efficient computation right
ah okay you're talking about using the
results from the
verification um
i think that would be an interesting
direction but i don't i don't
know about any any way to use it
currently
right so you are driven fully by machine
learning itself
right come again
so the motivation here is machine
learning
um yes i think also
also like applications in machine
learning also there's other
uh applications we can think of um
for instance um it might be possible to
use this kind of results for replication
of scientific publications
so you can imagine a situation where
somebody
um publishes you know does some
experiment
and get some results and then they
publish that and then traditionally what
happens in science is that people go and
replicate the experiment so they need to
repeat the whole experiment
and check that they get the same result
but maybe instead of just publishing the
original paper
what you could do is you could publish
your paper and also publish some sort of
prover
and then if somebody wants to verify
that publication what they can do is
maybe they can
um verify using uh
interactive proof with the approver and
that would allow them to
take less samples in the verification
process so instead of replicating the
whole publication
they're only going to be um taking less
samples
in their in their application so that's
that's one
additional kind of thing you might want
to do with with this verification
so do you envision there are going to be
additional applications
based on your paper which we do not
currently see in the
foreseeable future
um i think at the moment this is a
purely theoretical
theoretical thing i think in order to
make it uh practical we would need to
find
um interactive proof for verification
for
uh classes that are actually used in the
real world at the moment we have
um an example for a sort of toy class of
these vessels which i kind of described
in the top
um but you'd want to you'd want to get
results for actual stuff like
uh linear regression or decision trees
or
neural networks or some something that
it's more practical and then
that might actually be useful in the
real world great thanks thanks a lot
jonathan for this
answer um so maybe if there is
no more uh burning questions
uh i think this might be a good time uh
to end the session there is another
session
a very interesting one that just started
um so let me see no more question no
no more questions okay thanks to all the
speaker and
uh see you in the other session